if you were worried that the call of
duty black ops cold war beta was going
to be a repeat of the alpha
we have some good news it isn't let's
dig into what's new
including maps modes and quality of life
improvements
first off this beta will take place over
two weekends
the first phase goes to playstation
owners from thursday october 8th through
monday the 12th
the second weekend of the beta runs from
october 15th through the 19th
and includes all platforms looking at
you xbox and pc folks
the first two days are only for those
who have codes or pre-orders
but the ps4 crowd can play the whole
time the biggest addition to this beta
happens in the second week
and it's called fire team dirty bomb
fire team is cold war's largest mode
outside of war zone and it will include
two maps fire team splits 40 players
into 10 teams to compete in each match
the objective for dirty bomb is to run
around the map collecting uranium and
deposit it at bomb sites in order to
detonate them
detonating a bomb scores points for your
team but also a radiates part of the map
and be warned carrying uranium poisons
players by impacting perks
movement health regeneration and if
carried too long
it'll kill you if you do die fireteam
has a spawn system that is not currently
present in the other large scale mode
combined arms
you can parachute back in on your team
or spawn directly into vehicles
during the first week of the beta
combined arms which is cold war's 12v12
big team battle mode
is adding a new map called cartel and a
new game type called assault
players will start the match fighting
over a center objective and then work to
push the enemy further and further into
their own territory
capturing the enemy's final zone wins
the match each map will have five
capture zones
and tiebreakers will be decided by one
final battle
over the center capture point this
effectively turns each map into two maps
since you may wind up on just one side
or the other for an entire round
depending on which team takes the first
capture point
for those who enjoy core modes and vip
escort good news
the new cartel map is getting added into
the mix and it takes place in the
jungles of nicaragua
activision's blog post teases something
about the map's relation to the main
villain of cold war perseus
but it's unclear if this means map
secrets or if it's just based on a
location from the campaign
which is common for call of duty games
helping out players across
all modes is a new ping system that lets
you tag objectives
loot locations enemies and even score
streaks
there's also a field of view slider for
all platforms and a more customizable
hood
reaching level 10 in the beta will net
you this snazzy type 821 mutual
animosity weapon blueprint
and no it is not an uzi finally treyarch
has teased quote
frequent updates and a few surprises to
take place within the beta
so we're keeping our fingers crossed for
a zombie's appearance but no promises
cold war releases on november 13th so
head on over to gamespot to join us for
the latest announcements
thanks for watching
you